━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
内藤忍の資産デザイン研究所メール＜第六百九十七号2026年8月14日（金）発行＞
資産デザイン研究所メールは、資産運用に役立つ情報を個人投資家の皆様に提供するウィークリー・メールマガジンです。
金融資産だけではなく、不動産をはじめとする実物資産への投資まで、幅広い投資対象を組み合わせる「ハイブリッド投資」の具体的方法を可能な限り客観的な視点でご紹介いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
内藤忍公式ブログ
内藤忍、株式会社資産デザイン研究所は、資産配分などの投資アドバイスは行いますが、金融商品の勧誘・推奨などの投資助言業務は一切行っておりません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
【残席9名】【無料】金利上昇で不動産投資は大丈夫？
と心配する人のためのセミナー（9/14）
12年続く毎回好評の定番セミナー
9月も追加開催決定です
10名限定で東京ミッドタウン六本木で開催
総投資額20億円でわかった！
「不動産投資必勝法」
失敗しない物件の選び方、お金の借り方がわかります
不動産投資未経験者・初心者におススメです
詳しい内容とお申込みはこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ　〜　こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・勉強会のお知らせ
3　読者の質問コーナー
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
5　資産運用日記
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍の公式ブログ Shinoby`s World コラムタイトル一覧＞
毎日更新している公式ブログの、前回メールマガジン配信以降のコラムです。
こちらから全文をお読みいただけます
8月8日 長岡・大曲の花火大会に事前準備なしに出かけるのは「自殺行為」
8月9日 NTTドコモの「赤チャリ」は公共交通では無い
8月10日 雨の日に傘を差し出してくれた人も、傘を取り上げた人も絶対忘れない
8月11日 台風上陸で感じる「過剰なリスク回避」報道
8月12日 昔のヒット曲を歌うだけではファンは付いてこない
8月13日 8月が観光客のオンシーズンではなくなる日
8月14日 スタバは時間制限よりもダイナミックプライシング導入を
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜内藤忍のメディア出演・出版情報＞
【毎月更新】マネックス証券の投資情報サイト「マネクリ」
最新コラムタイトルは
「定期的なインカム収入が欲しいなら、高コストな毎月分配型ファンドではなく定期解約サービスを」
連載一覧はこちらから
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
1　資産デザインのすすめ〜こんしゅうの気になるテーマ
日銀が9月に利上げをすれば円高になるのか？
日銀がらいげつにも利上げ行うという見方がマーケットで急速に広がっています。
利上げは、日本と海外との金利差縮小をもたらすため理論的には円高要因として作用します。
しかし、実際の外国為替しじょうにおいては複雑な要因が絡み合うため一概に「日銀利上げ＝円高」とは言えません。
まず考えるべきはしじょうの「織り込み」の度合いです。
為替相場は常に未来の予測を先回りして動くため、9月の利上げがすでに多くの投資家に予想され市場価格に反映されている場合、実際に発表された瞬間に「材料出尽くし」として逆に円安へ押し戻されることもあり得ます。
反対に、しじょうの意図を突くようなサプライズ的な利上げであれば、一気に円高が進行する可能性が高まります。
また、利上げそのもの以上に決定後の日銀総裁会見や声明で示される「こんごの金融政策のスタンス」が大きな鍵を握ります。
こんごも継続的に金利を引き上げていくという強いメッセージが示されれば、持続的な円高トレンドを誘発しやすくなります。
さらに、海外の金融政策の動向も影響を与えます。
米国エフアールビーの利下げペースが遅れたり高い金利水準が維持されたりすれば、日米の絶対的な金利差は依然として開いたままとなり、ドルの底強さが残ることも考えられます。
9月の利上げ決定自体は経済学の教科書的には円高要因ですが、だから円高に向かうというほどマーケットは単純ではありません。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
2　本気でやる資産運用　〜　セミナー・イベントのご案内
【残席9名】【無料】金利上昇で不動産投資は大丈夫？
と心配する人のためのセミナー（9/14）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
3　読者の質問コーナー
読者からのご質問に、内藤忍がズバリ回答いたします！
Ｑ：中古ワンルームマンションなどの居住用賃貸物件は普通借家契約ではなく定期借家契約に切り替えた方が良いでしょうか？
Ａ：ご質問ありがとうございます。
居住用賃貸物件の契約形態を普通借家契約にするか定期借家契約（定借）にするかはそれぞれにメリット・デメリットがあり比較検討することがたいせつです。
定期借家契約の強みは契約期間の満了とともに確実に契約が終了する点です。
普通借家契約では正当な理由がない限り貸主からの解約や更新拒絶が困難ですが、定借であれば期間が来たら確実に立ち退いてもらえる安心感があります。
例えば数年後にご自身やご家族が住む予定がある場合や、将来の売却・建て替えが決まっている物件、あるいは転勤中の留守宅を貸し出すようなケースでは定借にすべきでしょう。
また、万が一近隣トラブルを起こすような不良入居者が入ってしまった場合でも更新しなければ期間満了のタイミングで確実に退出してもらえるというリスクヘッジにもなります。
定借は借り手からすると「住み続けられないかもしれない」という不安があるため、どうしても募集時の心理的ハードルが高くなります。
その結果、周辺の普通借家相場よりも賃料を安く設定せざるを得なかったり、入居者探しに時間がかかって空室期間が長引いたりする傾向があります。
また、ワンルームマンションのような単身者向けの狭い物件では定借物件の比率は高くなく入居者に受け入れられるまでにはもう少し時間がかかりそうです。
私は30平米を超えるような広めの物件については定借での募集を行い、それより狭い物件は普通借家契約で募集してもらっています。
将来的には狭い物件も入居者の反応を見ながら定借に切り替えていきたいと思っています。
このコーナーでは読者の方からのご質問に、資産デザイン研究所だいひょう取締役の内藤忍がメールマガジン上で回答いたします。
資産デザイン研究所
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
4　内藤忍の「白米ダイエット日記」
八丁堀で見つけた本格中華の穴場店
八丁堀で通りすがりに見つけた中華のお店に当日空席ありとの表示を見つけ、予約して出かけました。
ミシュランでビブグルマンのお店です。
単品でも注文できますが、初めて出かけたので、1人11,000円のコースを注文しました。
さいしょに出てきたのは、2種類のお肉でチャーシューと豚バラのクリスピー焼きです。
どちらも香ばしくジューシーな油の甘みがたまりません。
続いて出てきたクラゲや前菜の3種盛りもお酒によく合うお料理で、注文したフランスのリースリングと相性抜群です。
金華ハムと干し貝柱を使ったスープは奥深い味でこの日一番の味わいでした。
あわびの煮込みや〆の冷やしの麺も美味しく、さいごのマンゴーのデザートですっかりお腹いっぱいです。
シェフは三越前にあるマンダリンオリエンタルのケシキで修行したと言うことで、広東風の料理にその辺鱗を感じました。
サービスも良く、テーブル席でゆっくりと食事を楽しむことができました。
1人でカウンターに座り食事をとっている方もいました。
ワインの品揃えも工夫ですが、それ以外のドリンクも充実しています。
お酒を飲みながらおいしい中華料理をあれこれ楽しみたい人にはとても良いお店だと思います。
人気店なので、事前予約は必須です。
中国菜 漢
東京都中央区新川2-18-4 八重洲マンション 1F
03-6435-4850
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
5　資産運用日記
国産の限定ウイスキーを購入しました
ワイン、アンティークロレックス、アンティークコイン、日本刀といった実物資産を購入しています。
今回はブログにも書いたように国産の限定ウイスキーを購入しました。
プライスレスな価値を生むワインとウイスキー
ウイスキーのイベントで限定販売されている希少性の高いボトルで、全部で8本セットです。
生産数が限定されている実物資産はこんごさらに希少性が高まり価値の向上が期待できます。
またインフレによる貨幣価値の下落に対してもリスクヘッジになる資産です。
ご縁がある時にしか手に入れることができない実物資産はこれからも少しずつ購入していこうと思います。
（つづく）
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
6　内藤忍のつぶやき
自然災害が続く日本
こんしゅうは台風上陸で雨や風による被害が心配されましたが、台風が通過した後の大雨で千葉県を中心に大きな被害が発生しました。
熊本の地震に続き自然災害が続いていますが、平時からの備えがたいせつであることを再確認しました。
住まいには安全な場所を選ぶことは勿論、外出時に災害に遭遇した時の対応についてしっかり考えておくことが必須です。
これから更に自然災害が立て続けに発生しないことを祈るばかりです。
週末はいかがお過ごしですか？
私もこんしゅうはお盆のせいか仕事の予定がほとんどなく、週末もゆっくり過ごすことができそうです。
皆様も素敵な週末をお過ごしください。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
資産デザイン研究所メールの解除・変更はこちらから
ご意見・ご感想・
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
＜免責事項＞
内藤忍資産デザイン研究所メール（以下「本メール」）は資産デザイン研究所（以下「当社」）が発行するメールマガジンです。
本メールの著作権は当社に属します。
複製・再配信等を行う場合は当社までご一報をお願いいたします。
掲載された内容は、執筆時における筆者の見解・予測であり、情報の正確性や完全性を保証しません。
こんご予告なく変更することがあります。
また、過去の実績は、将来の結果を保証するものでもありません。
本メールは情報提供のみを目的としており、投資の最終判断はお客さまご自身の判断と責任で行いますようお願いいたします。
━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━━
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。